And the DQ principle is also very useful for managing graceful
degradation of service. So DQ defines to
total system capacity. So if a server is saturated, meaning that
we have reached the limit of the server in terms of DQ. That's a constant.
DQ's a constant. And so if you reach that limit, then we have a choice
of graceful degrading the service from the point
of view of the client. One possibility is
we keep the harvest the same meaning that
every client request that comes in has complete fidelity
in terms of the answers returned by the
server. So D is fixed. Q comes down because
DQ is a constant. That's one option. The
other option, of course, is to keep the volume
of clients that are service, that is the yield Q to be a constant, but decrease
the harvest. So the fidelity of the results returned to the users is less than.
100%, but we keeping more of the user community happy by serving more of them.
Because DQ is a constant, it allows us
to gracefully degrade the service being provided by
the server depending on the choice you want to make in terms of fidelity of the
result or the yield that you want to provide the user community. In other words.
The DQ principle gives us an explicit strategy
for managing saturation. So as a system administrator,
when we make these decisions on which to
sacrifice and which to keep constant, we know
how our decisions are going to affect the harvest,
how it's going to affect the yield. How it
is going to affect the up time and so
on. So the choices that a system provider has
or strategies that a system provider can use
in structuring the servers, knowing that DQ is
a constant, is when the server is saturated.
They can do cost based admission control. You pay
more, you get more. That may be one way to do it. Or priority or value based
admission control. That may be another way to
deal with service saturation or reduce data freshness. That
is the harvest may be the same, but
you reduce the fidelity of the data. For instance,
if I'm serving videos, and I can serve
the videos at different bit rates, if the server
is saturated, I might decide to serve the video to all the users, all the
videos that they want, but at a lower bit rate. So that is reducing the
fidelity. Of the data that is being harvested. So that's the idea behind the DQ
principle, how it might be used for graceful
degradation of service when the server is saturated.